I saw you at a MTV Movie Awards oh yeah
but you know you don't have to host
tonight yeah I know it's really lovely
like my friend more a man's has been
producing this show since the beginning
and my friend Jack bird has been riding
it since the beginning and I've been
here once before now I get to present
here and I'm such a massive sports fan
so I'm super geeking out like I just saw
sign what you said I didn't even know
what I didn't I didn't say anything I
just got a pedaled him on the back and I
kept moving I was like I'm sure
everybody wants to talk to him right now
okay but what happens when you meet
people who you geek out over do they
geek out right back over you your Shazam
well you know what now now after Shazam
you I get I get that a little bit more
some people were huge Chuck fans back in
the day or some people happen to be
tangled fans because they have kids but
now with Shazam it's a yeah it's it's a
little more level ground I guess I don't
know it's it's really fun I I spend so
much time consuming so much sports and
of all level like you're just watching
the women's soccer team win the
championship like soccer you know it
like the World Cup it's so so cool I was
just sitting at home of Texas and me and
my friends are watching it all go down
live in France technology is amazing and
be that our girls have continued to
dominate and dominate and dominate is
just so it's so cool it's very inspiring
I think it's very you know like from a
national perspective I find it very
inspiring and they're out there you know
not only dominating but using their
platform to fight for equal pay and how
do you feel watching them take on that
platform well I think I feel very
inspired by them doing that I think I
think the more we can all be fighting
for equality on all levels you know
between sexes between races between
faiths you know all of that I feel like
we need to be valuing and respecting
each other under equal levels and to the
extent that they're using their platform
to do that I think is a beautiful thing
can you reenact for me some of what your
face looked like or what you said when
you're watching that game it's a lot of
yeah it's like what you're hearing right
now is partly lost because I was so
excited for them we're asking everybody
you know Alex Morgan did she sipped her
tea she had her little dance move if you
were going to do a victory dance when
you just scored the winning goal what
would it look like I think I would
probably do like the robot or something
I could I've never seen anybody do the
robot for their victory dance I think
that would be pretty
bringing it back to the old school
because I'm an old fool who's so cool
never mind you can leave that up route
careers next yeah when I saw you at MTV
Movie own video or I'm sorry I'm TV
movie and TV Awards you talked to me
about how she's am too was was getting
going yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there
there there we're we're we're piecing
together a concept for a story right now
I had a great meeting with all my bosses
and producers and executives and our
awesome writer Henry Gaiden and we've
got a really cool idea I think
percolating and they're off to the races
with that what is that idea that what do
you gonna tell you that girl give me one
hit I'm in it
thank God what do you want to see happen
for him what do I want to see how for
Suzanne I don't know just more of the
all I want to do is make sure that we
don't lose the heart and the charm and
the joy bringing that we were able to do
in the first movie so long as we don't
lose that than I'm happy last question
you are always a stylish guy how do you
pick these suits you look slick Warren
Alfie Baker yeah Warren Alfie Baker he's
an incredible stylist I've basically
been using in my entire career through
thick and thin we've we've we've always
we've always seen very eye to eye he
understands he understands I like
thinking a little bit outside of the box
and I want some velvet corduroys some
some some violet some violet corduroy
sometimes that's just what you need how
you get the you know get the looks
that's right the loops the the Le wks is
that's how you do it mrs. Mazal that
show is so acclaimed we love you on it
where we see you on it again it is a
claim I appreciate that and I don't know
I don't know would you be up for it
of course I love those guys I would love
to but you know that they they're very
busy and doing what they're doing and
I've been super busy with all the Shazam
stuff so you know hopefully we can get
there do you know that UT theme I think
I do but I need a refresher yeah yeah
duh no no no no no no down out of time
dough no no no no
dantana no no no no no no no don't don't
don't don't don't don't
I mean come on since I was a little kid
you just did the keys you just did the
guitar we thank you you're welcome
you're welcome et
[Music]
[Applause]